[Applaudissements]
donc c'est pour thierry beccaro donc
tirer vous allez vous mettre ici c'est
la première épreuve
venez me voir vous allez devoir oui la
paix la boule noire je la garde
sam on fera une de plus bah quoi c'est
vrai donc on peut ramener les boules on
les ramène alors tout ça c'est pour les
invités que tu aimes bien oui mais
normalement et si vous n'aviez pas tirer
une boule noire ça aurait été alors je
vais vous dire c'est juste que j'ai
perdu ma fiche donc si j'osais bah ouais
vous n'avez pas de change relève
finalement
alors vous allez devoir et pelé qu'en
plongeant votre main là dedans oh la
vache correctement les trois mots que je
vais vous donner est tous que vous
n'avez pas bien et pelé vous laissez
votre main à l'intérieur en train de
tout dit d'accord
attention allez-y vous pouvez commencer
à tout y est allé gentil gentil avec les
cafards argentier quelqu'un
rj en plus t'as rien céder alors
attention ornithorynque were n é té
horizon-1 cul oui c'est bon attention
[Applaudissements]
deuxième vers le vérifier c'est bon
bravo au maire le vérifier deuxième au
bon soin olala c'est une horreur
d'accord parce que non c'est une
personne en fait c'est le c'est un
danseur de zouk fou qui vont avec
ivresse à m'inquiéter pas il se passe
des trucs dans cette émission et
regardez le zou regardez bien ce qu'on
va le faire après il sera temps siens
d'y regarder et c'est le seul qui a un
buzzer de questions pour un champion
[Rires]
alors attention deuxièmement khoudia man
cunha ont tous cogné à mal allons-y
alors ça ne m'a pas laissé partir alors
uni à mannheim qi c'est pas la petite
bête qui a mené la vie courante mais
sont ils sont vifs a vu comment pourquoi
j'ai pensé en voyant arriver la tête
alors kouign amann
alors ces éoliennes ah oui non non c'est
passé au yen alors qu'à ses cadres à
cacuaco hui tao eu quant au yen non car
oui mais quand oui
gn gn am non aman aman amaral quoi
[Musique]
à bâle
attention mais qu'est-ce que ça qu'est
ce que c'est de cette mascarade aller là
bas
eh bien c'était donc toucher à mon coin
voilà donc le pape arrive le dernier
levier rahmane mokhtar mokhtar mokhtar
dernier mot mokhtar belmokhtar allez-y
mm mais quand ouais t'es horaires non il
manque quelque chose est moche
ath quoi qui moctar mbow qu'à jeter
arriver là